il y a juste toutes sortes d'améliorations
qui pourraient être apportées mais Amazon ne
veut pas faire ces améliorations et rendre
le travail plus confortable l'amazon
veut garder ses résultats bas I
[Music]
rentrerais à la maison à 6 heures  horloge le
matin après avoir été allumé pendant 11 heures et
demie et je prendrais littéralement
autant d'ibuprofène que vous êtes médicalement
capable de mettre de la glace sur mon poignet sur
mes épaules
et je dormirais de cette façon en espérant que
l'inflammation  va descendre et le temps
pour mon prochain quart de travail et pendant des semaines et
des semaines c'était comme ça
[Music]
nous ne sommes pas antisyndicaux mais nous ne sommes pas
neutres non plus la façon dont Amazon étouffe vraiment
toute discussion sur
la syndicalisation il y a vraiment une sorte de  un
sentiment que les gens sont coincés, ils doivent le supporter
il n'y a pas de moyen d'améliorer les choses
et si vous n'aimez pas ça, vous êtes
inutile
[Musique]
au lieu de programmer les gens de
manière appropriée en fonction de leurs
prévisions, ils font venir tout le monde pour
un quart de travail et au sommet du quart de travail, ils ont
annoncé qu'ils avaient un VTO disponible,
que vous ayez conduit, vous savez à
cinq minutes ou à plus d'une heure,
ils recherchent des personnes qu'ils peuvent
renvoyer chez eux en haut du quart de travail  et donc
cela met tout le
risque de cette main-d'œuvre flexible sur les
employés réels, l'employé ne
reçoit aucun salaire s'il prend le
congé volontaire, il n'obtient rien et Amazon
parvient alors à maintenir ses coûts aussi minimes
que possible  Les pratiques d'Amazon peuvent
changer, nous avons vu qu'elles sont
sensibles aux pressions de l'extérieur
lorsque Bernie Sanders a présenté le
projet de loi d'arrêt de Bezos, il a vraiment poussé Bezos à
augmenter le salaire minimum. Je pense
que cela devra être une base vraiment
ascendante.  type de campagne pour
pousser cette
[Musique]
vous